hannover davis luca meine liebe freunde
ich habe seit einem jahr kein fortnight
mehr gespielt und dann hab ich mir
gedacht frage ich euch doch einfach mal
auf instagram ob ich heute zur
abwechslung mal wieder ein ford leid
video zwischen den ganzen minecraft
videos hochladen soll und da hatte
eigentlich keiner so richtig bock drauf
ich habe da allerdings bock drauf
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht spielen
heute mal wieder eine runde so loben
einer lieben freundin bevor wir das
allerdings thun ganz kurz und der
spitzenreiter luke also wenn ihr euch
etwas bei fortnight haufen möchtet könnt
ihr da luca eingeben
jetzt hat nix mehr aber ich verdiene
meine milliarden dadurch sparte auf
beginn der spielersuche kann sein dass
ich so ein schlechtes level habe das
jetzt keine spieler findet zweiter sind
jahre später hier sind auf jeden fall
einige spieler am start
[Musik]
türen öffne den fünf sekunden meine
lieben freunde das hier ist also die
fortnight welt ich habe das wirklich so
lange nicht mehr gespielt als ich hab
keine ahnung was hier abgeht ich bin
einfach mal direkt raus und gehen dahin
sieht aus wie hamburg da mit dem strand
und sorgen bei euch so ich habe keine
ahnung ob noch irgendwer fordert spielt
allerdings habe ich auch in meiner
instagram story gesehen dass drei
viertel überhaupt keinen bock hatten das
ganze hochladen wie sprintet man denn
hier noch mal schneller in minecraft ist
das auf steuerung aber hier geht
irgendwie gar nichts mehr so richtig hab
das spiel extrem lange nicht mehr
gespielt nach laden geht auf rwe haben
daran gegner oben ist gegner
[Musik]
der profi der gal
ich bin gegen alkohol
das geht nicht kaputt welches abbauen
richter allerdings nicht
[Musik]
das ist wenig erzählen dass das richtige
spieler sind es ziemlich geil hier das
ganze kann ich hier nicht mal ganz kurz
eben aber zurück nach 2014 bitte ich
würde sagen ich bewege mich jetzt
erstmal in die zone rein ich habe
irgendwo mal in videos gesehen dass man
auch irgendwie mit autos fahren kann
oder somit lag
[Musik]
da die ganzen klubs geschlossen haben
hier stellt das jäger der nato
wie sollte er in lambo
und leute zwei macsteel und ich habe nur
seine kanada oder was wir jagen jetzt
einfach mal dem lambo hinterher ich weiß
nicht wo da hingefahren ist allerdings
sieht ja auch schon oben recht dass ich
noch nichts hiervon entdeckt habe dass
hier gerade allerdings schon beinahe
kollision wir müssen auf jeden fall auch
in welchen gegner töten ich habe mir das
ziel gesetzt dass ich hier auf jeden
fall erste taxi
[Musik]
neue runde neues glück freunde wir
fliegen ab ins atomkraftwerk das eine
gute idee ist es war keine gute idee
denn ab dem zeitpunkt wo ich in dieses
beschissene atomkraftwerk reingeflogen
bin hat meine kamera sich gedacht mensch
[Musik]
den hintergrund und da will ich sagen
machen wir jetzt in der runde weiter wo
das dann zwar immer noch zu beginn so
jetzt aber irgendwas machen das sieht
auf jeden fall ziemlich krass hier aus
ist klar ich das ganze spiele seit einem
jahr nicht gespielt also da sind
wahrscheinlich eine menge sachen dazu
gekommen erst sie sich ja schon total
aus also wir gehen jetzt mal hier vorne
hoch nehmen uns hier die schrotflinte
das ist sogar wirklich eine schrotflinte
das habe ich natürlich direkt erkannt
hier ist
die kiste
die
kann man ihm
[Musik]
jetzt haben ich konzentriere mich lieber
auf die sachen die ich keine bäume
fällen meine lieben freunde autos
aussieht mit den ganzen grafiken und so
das haben sie schon gut gemacht
mittlerweile hier in fortnight da würd
ich mal direkt in kreta kommt luca
benutzen nehmer ganz kurz real talk ich
weiß nicht ob mein trader kommt
überhaupt noch existiert aber wenn er
existieren sollte könnt ihr gern nehmen
und wenn ich dann ist auch nicht stimmen
aber ich habe mir gedacht so lang in
fordern mehr gespielt mal gucken was
hier so abgeht mal gucken ob ich noch
kann also ich kann es halt irgendwie nie
aber das hat mich noch nie davon
abgehalten spieler zu spielen von wir
schauen uns das ganze jetzt einfach mal
an und ich bin auch ganz ehrlich bevor
er morgen kommt der serbische und aber
nicht töten naja ich habe ja bloß hatte
strömung ich sagte mir hey luca heute
ist ebenfalls hier merken coolen
[Musik]
ich habe mir auf jeden fall gedacht hey
luca du hast ja heute deinen upload
freien tag
da kannst du eigentlich dann meine runde
fordert wiederbringen morgen geht es
weiter mit minecraft da werden wir dann
in die höhle mal entdecken da hinten in
dem dorf was in der letzten folge
entdeckt habe mich immer ganz präzise
medi kit weil ich schon wieder halb
droht würden von dieser komischen
festung nach vorne wieder eine runde vor
neid guckt man sich als apparat machen
wird wahrscheinlich überhaupt keine
klicks machen weil ich auch schon mal
gesehen habe dass eigentlich keiner so
richtig bock drauf hat aber ich möchte
mal wieder bemerkbar wieder spielen und
wer hat früher mal ganz viel spaß macht
und wo ich nicht wirklich gut darin war
und vor ihnen jemand und sagt du kannst
das ja gar nicht was kann ich hier lasse
ich das nicht auf wegschmeißt an jetzt
in minecraft kann ich dann sachen
wegschmeißen
aha so der profi aber nie in den kampf
leute wir scheuen keine gefahr sind
wieder fische weg mit euch
wir hatten vorne auf jeden fall gerade
jenen gegner und den knöpfe ich mir
jetzt vor ich weiß zwar nicht wo der ist
da ist eine feuerstelle wo ist der
gegner besser gelaufen hat angst vor mir
gesehen ich bin level 4 mittlerweile
alter da manchmal ganz schnell die biege
die vorne schnell noch eben die munition
mit dem besser
jetzt sehen wir aber von allen seiten
beschuss
ich habe auch in mein auto
ich höre irgendwo ein auto wir müssen
uns allerdings erst mal um den typen da
oben kann man vielleicht haben wir ja
irgendwo eine show wie heißt das auch
wenn man auf entfernung
ich sortiere ich grad
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der stelle möchte ich heute minecraft
mit lucasarts was von ford mit luca wie
bereits gesagt das ganze game lange zeit
nicht mehr gezockt hab mir deswegen mal
gedacht hey jetzt mal wieder eine folge
davon hohe fenster gefallen hat der lask
einen daumen hoch und haben video hier
da abonnieren kann allenfalls noch kein
teil der news seite und klickt gern auf
die glocke und falls ihr das so spielen
solltet dann luca ich weiß nicht ob das
noch funktioniert wir sehen uns morgen
20 uhr bei der neuen folge minecraft
[Musik]